wearing the colors is how the faithful
have always backed their team
but in the 21st century selling scarves
and shirts only goes so far and clubs
like arsenal are chasing fans around the
world and they're using cryptocurrency
to do it
so this is the london office yeah london
uh we are growing we're gonna take
another floor actually as well arsenal
are one of five premier league clubs
that have done a deal with this man alex
dreyfus runs socios.com which sells
crypto backed fan tokens he says are
meant to be fun not a financial
investment the value that is provided is
not financial and will never be
financial the value that is provided is
about the experience and the
relationship between me the fan and the
club
we believe that 99 of sports fans are
not in the stadium and therefore clubs
need to offer more and more digital
tools towards these funds
fan tokens work like this you use real
money to buy a cryptocurrency which you
then use to buy the tokens which will
give you a vote in club matters usually
trivial issues like what song they might
play at half time perhaps what color the
away shirt should be and then those
tokens can also be traded now clubs love
them because they've conjured hundreds
of millions of dollars of value
apparently from thin air but regulators
are concerned they think
cryptocurrencies are risky and they're
scrambling to keep up with this new
market if you're only investing for the
big wins it can be easy to get caught up
in the hype the financial conduct
authority has taken to tick-tock to warn
younger investors of the risks of
cryptocurrencies and is clamping down on
misleading marketing
football fan tokens are complicated
they are in the majority outside our
perimeter so outside our regulatory
regime the overall message of our
investment campaign is very much wanting
to make sure that people understand the
level of risk that crypto generally
poses
and ensure that they can sensibly make
decisions themselves arsenal fans have
spent five million dollars on fan tokens
since they launched they're worth less
than half as much now and last month the
club was criticized by advertising
regulators for trivializing crypto
investments i know from talking to
supporter groups at everton west ham
manchester city and elsewhere but
there's a lot of concern that they're
being introduced at their clubs and i
think we need to see more education and
perhaps more rules from the premier
league and from the government before
this continues
cryptocurrencies are here to stay and
fan tokens offer clubs yet another way
to monetize supporter loyalty
the risk may be to fans playing a new
game in which they barely understand the
rules paul kelso sky news